[Music]
the listless movement of spirit which no
longer creates a distinction within
itself has thus entered into its own
self beyond consciousness which on the
other hand sees itself clearly the first
movement of this clarity is determined
in its necessity and condition by the
fact that pure insight or insight that
is implicitly notion actualizes itself
it does so when it posits other nets are
determinate nests within itself in this
way it is negative pure insight that is
a negation of the notion this negation
is equally pure and thus there is come
into being the pure thing the absolute
being that has no further determination
whatever characterized more precisely
pure insight quat absolute notion is a
distinguishing of differences which are
no longer differences of abstractions or
pure notions which are no longer
self-supporting but are supported and
distinguished only by the movement as a
whole this distinguishing of what
contains no difference consists simply
in the fact that the absolute notion
makes itself into its object and posits
itself as the essence over against that
movement this results in the essence
being without that side wherein
abstractions or differences are held
apart and therefore becomes pure thought
in the form of a pure thing this then is
just the listless unconscious movement
to and fro within itself of spirit to
which faith was reduced when it lost a
content that contained a difference it
is at the same time that movement of
pure self consciousness for which the
essence is supposed to be the absolutely
alien beyond for because this pure self
consciousness moves about impure notions
in differences that are not differences
it collapses in fact into the
unconscious movement to and fro spirit
that is in
pure feeling or pure thing hood the self
alienated notion for the notion here is
still standing at the stage of this
alienation does not however recognize
this identical essence of the two sides
the movement of self-consciousness and
of its absolute being does not recognize
their identical essence which is in fact
their substance and enduring being since
the notion is unconscious of this unity
absolute being has value for it only in
the form of a Beyond standing over
against it while the consciousness
making these distinctions and in this
way having the in itself outside of it
is held to be a finite consciousness
in paragraph 574 we are now entering a
new sub portion of this enlightenment
section this one is very short and is
called the truth of the enlightenment so
the question we have to ask is well what
is the truth of the enlightenment and
that is something that we've already
started to see right in the development
in the struggle of the enlightenment
with superstition which turns out to be
about the enlightenment and it's a views
on and critiques of faith and some of
the responses that can be made by faith
to to enlightenment at the end of that
section faith has essentially lost the
game and now enlightenment or pure
insight dominates the field and so the
question is well what is the truth that
it possesses and what you see in this is
very metaphysical beginning paragraph
which is quite long really can be boiled
down to saying that what we're talking
about here is a self alienated notion in
which spirit as he says goes to and fro
it doesn't really have something to
latch on to and why why is that the case
because again to use a phrase that that
Hegel has brought up many times what
we're dealing with at this point not not
across the board entirely but at this
point is a distinction of things that
should be determinate without a real
difference between them and so in order
to have truth of enlightenment we're
going to need difference and that
requires other nuts so let's walk our
way now through what it is that he's
saying so he talks about this listless
movement of spirit no longer creating a
distinction within itself he says it is
entered into its own self beyond
consciousness which on the other hand
sees itself clearly so we already do
have a distinction there right the
spirit on the one hand and consciousness
which is going to be self consciousness
understanding itself is finite and he
says the first moment of this clarity is
determined in its necessity and
condition
by the fact that pure insight or insight
that is implicitly notion actualizes
itself okay so what what does that mean
what is the first moment of that the
first moment of this is you know the the
spirit right which which is going back
and forth and he says pure insight or
insight that is implicitly notion
implicitly concept implicitly something
that connects things together actualizes
itself and again a very common pengallan
point in order for the the rational or
the ideal to be what it's supposed to be
it has to become actual has to become
veer clique right it has to engage
itself in in the world and a project it
has to become practical so he says how
does it do this
here's a quija galleon point it does so
when it posits other nests or
determinate nests within itself over and
over again in the Hegelian dialectic
we're going to see that in order to
become real in order to engage the world
in order to have projects that mean
anything that you throw yourself into
there has to be all Terra T other
necessity of splitting and this can take
many many different forms it can be the
difference realizing the difference
between means and ends it can be you
know thinking about the nature of
another self-consciousness in your
relation to it it happens in in a myriad
different ways but this is really
fundamental to the Hegelian dialectic
without this there is no advance so the
key then is in some respect to get the
right kind of other although sometimes
you don't have much of a choice about
that and then to figure out how you
bring them together how do you get past
how do you reconnect them so he says in
this way it is negative perience like a
negation of the notion a negation of the
concept this negation
he says his equally pure and thus there
has come into being the pure thing
absolute being the pure thing absolute
being as something that just is all
right now he says that this is part of
what happened through the Enlightenment
and we're gonna see how this gets worked
out in later paragraphs he says this has
no further determination whatever we saw
that earlier characterized more more
precisely pure insight as the absolute
notion is a distinguishing of
differences which are no longer
differences of abstractions or pure
notions which are no longer
self-supporting but are supported and
distinguished only by the movement as a
whole so we have a distinction being
made but it's not a distinction that is
going to be particularly workable or
useful for self consciousness so what
should it do then how should it manage
this well he goes on he says this
distinguishing of what contains no
difference so we have here again a
distinction but it's not really a
distinction in the fullest sense a
distinction when we make a distinction
like say between means and ends means
are different than ends how are they
different we use this word difference
quite a quite a lot too
this is worth dwelling on when a
difference really matters you have some
way of articulating how these things are
fundamentally different from en maybe
still connected with each other there is
a contrast there what would be the
opposite of that imagine a paper where
you're just filling in you know schemas
of means and ends and you're not really
thinking about it and you just sort of
plunking things down in there as if
they're there you know homework for you
to do busy work as we say that's a
distinction without a difference so he
goes on and he says it consists in the
fact that absolute notion makes itself
into its object
posits itself as the essence over
against that movement so the absolute
object is going to make it the actual
absolute notion is going to make itself
into its own object and we're going to
see that this will involve subjectivity
but for right now we have this polarity
of the pure thing right and then we have
the consciousness that is actually
trying to make sense of this so he says
that the results are in the essence
being held without that side we're in
abstractions or differences are held
apart therefore becomes pure thought in
the form of a pure thing absolute being
when he says this then is just as
listless unconscious notice what he's
saying there unconscious we're talking
about consciousness it's the
phenomenology of spirit or mind which is
the development of consciousness we have
some unconscious things going on here so
he says it's it's it's a here we go it's
the unconscious movement to and fro of
spirit I think says what is this to
generate into mere feeling mirror
effectivity pure thing hood but he says
the self alienated notion for the notion
of standing at the stage of this
alienation of being opposite of being
alien to itself does not recognize the
identical essence of the two sides it
doesn't recognize that self
consciousness and absolute being are in
fact part of the same movement you could
say that the the self alienated notion
or it's spirit if you like is not aware
of itself it's just you know reacting
it's just understanding it's developing
but it's not taking a conscious guidance
of that so he goes on and he says the
movement of self-consciousness as
absolute being doesn't recognize they're
at their identical essence which is
their substance and enduring being and
he says since the notion is unconscious
of this unity
absolute being has value for it only in
the form of beat beyond standing over
against it well the consciousness
so the real thinking going on this side
is unselfconsciousness side the
consciousness making these distinctions
and having the in itself outside of it
is held to be a finite consciousness so
what we have here is a sort of division
that's taking place and we don't have
anything yet overcoming that that's
going to happen as we move through this
section so the truth of self
consciousness there's the truth rather
of enlightenment is something yet to be
realized
in regard to that absolute being
enlightenment is caught up in the same
internal conflict that had formerly
experienced in connection with faith and
it divides itself into two parties one
party proves itself to be victorious by
breaking up into two parties for in so
doing it shows that it contains within
itself the principle it is attacking and
thus has rid itself of the one-sidedness
in which it previously appeared the
interest which was divided between
itself and the other party now falls
entirely within itself and the other
party is forgotten because that interest
finds within itself the antithesis which
occupies its attention at the same time
however it has been raised into the
higher victorious element in which it
exhibits itself in a clarified form so
that the schism that arises in one of
the parties and seems to be a misfortune
demonstrates rather that parties good
fortune
paragraph 575 really sets the tone for
what is going to be taking place in the
rest of the section more than the
preceding paragraph I would say in part
because what Hegel is is doing here he
says that it in regard to that absolute
being right so we've got this polarity
of absolute being and self-consciousness
and with regard to that absolute being
he says enlightenment is going to split
into two two different ways of looking
at it two different parties this is
incredibly important and so I would say
there's probably more going on in this
short paragraph there wasn't a longer
paragraph preceding it so he says in
regard to that absolute being
enlightenment is caught up in the same
internal conflict it formerly
experienced in connection with faith so
what was the the conflict that it had
experienced in terms of faith faith and
pure insight were both forms of thought
and both of them were trying to sort of
share the same space but unable to do so
and insight was in a certain way the
negation of of faith which itself
contains some negations within it as we
saw as we went through it
phenomenologically now that faith is no
longer there to function as a foil can
enlightenment simply say all right we
won let's get on with our project no
because inevitably what it finds once it
no longer has that that opposition to
something else and starts working out
its own projects and looking more
closely at itself and at its object it's
sort of like saying oh you know well I
thought everything was gonna be great
and simple once we got this this this
crazy pain-in-the-rear person out of the
house and now the house is so quiet and
you start looking around you're like oh
I never noticed how dusty things are in
here or that I did I never unpacked all
those boxes or you know that maybe I
don't like being by myself and you start
talking to yourself okay this is very
metaphorical but that's what's going on
with enlightenment so he says
enlightenment divides itself into two
parties and here Hegel you know is
telling us something quite interesting
one party and he's using the word partay
there right so sort of one faction one
one one grouping proves itself to be
victorious when it breaks up into two
parties and this is often the case in
politics right we see a successful party
that comes to so dominate the scene that
its opposition really vanishes is going
it's probably going to split into two
parties and become two different
entities how by emphasizing different
principles and each one can represent it
this way that it is the one party it has
a principle and there's another
principle that it's attacking that the
other party represents and and both of
them you know can confuse things in this
way so why is this important he says the
same thing enlightenment contains within
itself the principle it is attacking and
it's rid itself of the one-sidedness
anxiety Kate right which it in which it
previously appeared so in a way you
could say enlightenment couldn't really
be what it was and display its own inner
contradictions that it has to work
through while faith was still dominating
the scene or at least you know
presenting a rearguard action that it
constantly had to fight against once
enlightenment takes over the culture
enlightenment can start splitting into
enlightenment or at least different
interpretations of enlightenment again
something really great to keep in mind
for the contemporary defenders of
enlightenment there is no one single
enlightenment thing that everybody from
you know bacon all the way through
Kant's we're all involved in they didn't
agree on everything right and it's very
there
important to be clear which
enlightenment we're talking about not
just to you know because if we're not
then we're doing what Hegel calls
picture language you know or poor Stella
representation or even worse just
appealing to feeling good food now
that's not enlightenment at all
enlightenment is about working out the
concept conceptual thinking able to take
its opposition into itself and not be
one-sided so he says the interest and he
uses this word you know interest here
which was divided between itself and the
other party now falls with him entirely
within itself the other party's
forgotten faith has is no longer the
real issue because why that interest
finds within itself the antithesis the
Gagen Zots
between the two parties between the two
principles which occupies its attention
culturally the Enlightenment stops
focusing on attacking faith and starts
focusing on trying to figure out what
the hell the world is about and how to
fix it
and what to do so he says at the same
time it's been raised into the higher
victorious element in which it exhibits
itself in a clarified form so the schism
the splitting right that occurs in one
of the parties and seems to be
misfortune demonstrates rather that
parties good fortune who was the party
here the party is enlightenment itself
as opposed to faith
so splitting into two is actually a good
thing it's going to bring out all sorts
of matters that need to be clarified
the pure essence itself has no
difference in it consequently the way in
which it does obtain a difference is
that to such pure essences exhibit
themselves for consciousness or there is
a two-fold consciousness of the essence
pure absolute being is only in pure
thought or rather it is pure thought
itself and therefore utterly beyond the
finite beyond self consciousness and is
only being in a negative sense but in
this way it is just mere being the
negatives of self consciousness as the
negative of self consciousness it is
also related to it it is an external
being which related to self
consciousness within which differences
in determination fall receives within at
the differences of being tasted seen etc
and the relationship is that of sense
certainty and perception
paragraph 576 is telling us a little bit
more about this dualism or duality
within the heart of enlightenment that
Hegel has been talking about for the
past two paragraphs in this section so
he says that if we if we think about it
in terms of pure essence or as he's
gonna say pure absolute being it doesn't
have any difference within it and we saw
that what's really important here for
the development of the Enlightenment is
that it does have difference within it
so how is this difference that we know
is supposed to be there going to
manifest itself he says the way in which
it does obtain a difference is that two
such pure essences exhibit themselves
for consciousness and then he
immediately says or there is a two-fold
consciousness of the essence so it's not
as if there really are two distinct
essences there are two different ways in
which consciousness is taking cognizance
of this this essence and they're going
to argue with each other and contest
with each other during the period of the
Enlightenment about which of them has it
right and and you know the irony is of
course they both have it right and they
both have it wrong and in some way so he
says pure absolute being is only in pure
thought or rather it is pure thought
itself so the the pure essence can be
understood as thought but it's also
grasped by consciousness through the
modality of thought so he says this is
therefore utterly beyond the finite
beyond self consciousness and is only
being in a negative sense that means
that the thinking that is grasping pure
essence as thought is in a certain way
not fully adequate to it or you might
say it's not able to entirely grasp what
that pure thought is on that side so
perhaps the grass
as a void was less a reflection of
what's actually out there and more a
reflection of the lack of capacity to
fully understand it that consciousness
had on its side and that's one that's
one way in which the pure essence is
manifesting itself in the modality of
thought so he says in this way it's just
mere being the negative of
self-consciousness as the negative of
self-consciousness
it is also related to it so this brings
us to the second way of understanding
what is what is going on here what this
pure essence consists in we can picture
to ourselves or you know imagine or
however else you want to talk about it
some sort of pure thing that just
doesn't have any predicate it just is
what it is pure being itself the
absolute but that doesn't work for very
long
we need some ways to make sense of it
and we have to think about well if the
there's an absolute out there what what
is all this stuff that we're seeing and
hearing and smelling what is the world
what is this body that I have what is
this chalkboard or you know you're
looking at this through you know what's
happening in a camera right now you're
looking at it on some sort of screen
what is that so Hegel says to go back
just a little bit as the negative of
self consciousness the absolute is the
negative self conscious it is also
related to it now here's where he brings
in the second modality it is an external
being which related to
self-consciousness within which
differences and determination fall
receives within it differences and what
are those differences here he says these
are differences of being tasted seen and
so forth well what are those those are
modes of perception of sense perceptions
so he says the relationship is that of
sense certainty and perception so
what are we seeing here well remember
back to the section that we just
traversed and the Enlightenment view on
things which was that the absolute is
this void without predicate and yet the
world is this sensuous world and now the
question is how do we reconnect these
together and what's going to be
happening is there will be two different
perspectives and these are going to be
two different ways of understanding what
it is that the absolute in fact is what
is the pure essence what is pure
absolute being and how is it related to
consciousness one way is going to grasp
it through thought and focus on it in
that way the other is going to grasp it
through sense certainty and perception
and grasp it through that but both of
them are attempting to grasp what the
absolute is and how self consciousness
fits into that absolute
you